[Music]
insulin pumps improve the lives of many
of the 415 million people with diabetes
around the world by monitoring blood
sugar delivering insulin and preventing
the need for constant finger picking and
blood testing these small machines
include a pump and a needle which
consents glucose levels feedback to the
pump and then calculate how much insulin
to deliver through the needle but they
have a catch they're temporary within a
few days glucose sensors have to be
moved and replaced and it's not just
glucose monitors and insulin pumps that
have this problem but all bodily
implants at different time scales
plastic prosthetic knees have to be
replaced after about 20 years other
implants such as those used for cosmetic
reasons can meet the same fate in about
ten that isn't just a nuisance that can
be expensive and risky this
inconvenience happens because of our
body's immune systems honed by several
hundred million years of evolution these
defensive fronts have become
exceptionally good at identifying
foreign objects our immune systems
boasts an impressive arsenal of tools to
tackle intercept and destroy anything
they believe shouldn't be there for the
consequence of this constant
surveillance is that our bodies treat
helpful implants like insulin pumps with
the same suspicion as they would a
harmful virus or bacteria as soon as the
insulin pump has been implanted in the
skin its presence triggers what's known
as a foreign body response this starts
with free-floating proteins that stick
themselves to the surface of the implant
those proteins include antibodies which
attempt to neutralize the new object and
send out a signal that calls other
immune cells to the site to strengthen
the attack early responding inflammatory
cells like neutrophils and macrophages
respond to the emergency call
neutrophils release little granules
filled with enzymes that try to break
down the surface of the insulin pumps
needle macrophages secrete enzymes -
together with nitric oxide radicals
create a chemical reaction that degrades
the object over time if the macrophages
are unable to dispatch the foreign body
rapidly they fuse together forming a
mass of cells called a giant cell at the
same time cells called fibroblasts
traveled to the site and begin to
deposit layers of dense connective
tissue those enclosed the needle that
the pump uses to deliver insulin and
tests for glucose levels over time this
scaffolding builds up forming a scar
around the implant
the scarf functions as an almost
impenetrable wall that might start to
block vital interactions between the
body and the implant
for example scarring around pacemakers
can interrupt the electrical
transmission that's crucial for their
functioning synthetic knee joints may
give off particles as they're worn down
causing immune cells to inflame around
these fragments tragically the immune
systems attack can even be
life-threatening however researchers are
finding ways to trick the immune system
into accepting the new devices we
introduced into our bodily tissues we've
discovered that coating implants with
certain chemicals and drugs can dampen
the immune response those basically make
the implant invisible to the immune
system we're also making more implants
out of natural materials and in forms
that directly mimic tissues so that the
body launches a weaker attack than it
would if it came across a completely
artificial implant some medical
treatments involve implants designed to
regenerate lost or damaged tissues in
those cases we can design the implants
to contain ingredients that will release
specific signals and carefully tailor
our body's immune reactions in the
future this way of working alongside the
immune system could help us develop
completely artificial organs totally
integrated processes and self-healing
wound therapies these treatments might
one day revolutionize medicine and
transform forever the bodies we live in
if you'd like to learn more about how
the immune system protects your body
check out this video
[Music]